Online platforms such as Google and Facebook
can promote groupthink, a mob mentality that
discourages creativity and individual responsibility.
You might have noticed that platforms and
websites show you content you already agree
with.
It's also evident that groupthink has become
part of the management of these companies.
For example, Google fired James Damore for
advancing what was called "harmful gender
stereotypes."
And Facebook has suppressed news it considered
to be conservative.
Now, people are calling for the government
to regulate these tech giants.
That's the wrong approach.
The First Amendment states that "Congress
shall make no law abridging the freedom of
speech."
But for years, regulators have been exacerbating
the problem with policies such as Title II
Net Neutrality, which concentrates power with
online platforms.
To create a marketplace of ideas online, regulators
should remove the barriers to entry which
limit the ability of other companies to compete
in the online advertising space.
If forced to compete for ad dollars, Silicon
Valley would have less incentive to placate
its own bias and the market will have more
meaningful platforms for different kinds of
speech.
To learn more about my take on platform competition,
check out the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you want
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.